Let's create a button band
with a beautiful edge finish.
This method can use any
needle arrangement.
I chose to knit my band
in full needle rib.
Knit the band separately with a nice
tubular cast on and then attach
it to the front garment edge.
Start by establishing the number
of needles needed for your edge.
Cast on using the method of your choice.
I'm using my favorite Broken Toe Cast On.
Once the cast on is complete,
set up for the needle arrangement of your
choice and knit the number
of rows for your band.
Transfer all the stitches up
to the main bed and knit one row.
Knit a row of ravel cord and scrap off.
Now set that band aside
and with the right side facing,
rehang the garment edge,
pushing it back behind the latches.
Next, pick up the band stitches with
the wrong side of the band facing you.
Place these stitches
in the hooks of the needles.
When all the stitches are on the machine,
close the latches and pull the band
stitches through the garment edge
and loosely bind off.
This bind off is a bit bulky.
You may want to use a sewn or
a backstitch bind off instead.
By knitting the band separately,
we can take advantage of that beautiful
cast on edge for the edge of our band.